Bundesinnenminister Horst Seehofer hat die
Todesfahrt von Münster bei einem Besuch des
Tatorts als feiges und brutales Verbrechen
verurteilt.
Gemeinsam mit dem nordrhein-westfälischen
Ministerpräsidenten Armin Laschet und Innenminister
Herbert Reul gedachte er am Sonntag vor dem
Gasthaus "Grosser Kiepenkerl" der Toten.
Polizei und Rettungskräften dankte er für
ihre schnelle und professionelle Arbeit.
Mehr Klarheit über das Tatmotiv konnte der
Bundesinnenminister
zunächst allerdings nicht schaffen.
Es gebe starke Hinweise, dass es sich um einen
Einzeltäter handle und kein Bezug zur Terrorszene bestehe.
Die Sicherheitslage in Deutschland sei dennoch
angespannt, sagte Seehofer.
"Die ist extrem angespannt, unsere Sicherheitslage.
Das muss man immer wieder sagen.
Aber wir tun auch was, Polizeipräsenz und
all dieses.
Schauen Sie - da war ein Streifenwagen praktisch
um die Ecke.
Dann wäre alles möglicherweise anders abgelaufen,
wenn die Polizei nicht präsent gewesen wäre."
Im Anschluss gab Polizeipräsident Hans-Joachim
Kuhlisch
einen kurzen Einblick in die bisherigen Ermittlungen.
"Wir haben seit gestern Nachmittag in der
ganzen Nacht die Wohnungen des Täters durchsucht.
Sie werden verstehen: Bei vier Wohnungen,
zwei davon in Ostdeutschland, zwei in Münster,
können wir jetzt nicht abschließend sagen,
dass wir da gar nichts finden würden.
Aber die erste, doch schon etwas intensivere
Durchsicht, hat keinerlei Hinweise auf einen
politischen Hintergrund ergeben.
Das ist - wie gesagt - ein vorläufiger Stand."
Kuhlisch äußerte sich nicht dazu, weshalb
der Täter vier Wohnungen hatte.
Derartige Sachverhalte seien aber bei diesem
Täterprofil nicht ungewöhnlich und müssten
nicht unbedingt auf einen kriminellen Hintergrund
hindeuten.